so thank you
for for bringing me here so um actually
i could
maybe start start my talk by introducing
myself so i'm chuck
and you can see from the screen that
there are all my credentials so this is
like how you could find me
i will be also hanging around on discord
a lot so feel free to chat to me and um
we could also maybe carry on chatting in
the in the
channels in the discord server and
um also i am doing some uh tutorials on
twitch so i actually stream four
times a week and also uh you know i know
liz is here and my co-host uh for for
the program today earlier at lunchtime
is today here uh
lace is also you know a active member in
the community so we do a podcast uh
every week about python so um feel free
to have a look there
and so i've already introduced a little
bit about myself
and um also i i'm an enthusiast about
open source project
first of all because um i was actually
like i would tell you a little bit more
about myself i was a data scientist
and that's why i kind of i'm still kind
of involved in all these like
data communities as well um but i really
love open source project i will tell you
why
and i will tell you how i become you
know contributed to open source project
and now i work through
time for an open source uh software
that's terminusdb it's a graph database
it's totally open source
and um so i kind of i
i i create a python client although like
it's not just me
it's like a team effort but i kind of
pretty much uh
in charge of it but now and um i really
love it because like i can work uh
you know for open source uh that's
really like a dream come true
and also you know i i do a lot of
uh you know organized meetups and
conferences especially i like
organizing sprints uh i would also tell
you a little bit more about sprints in
this talk
and uh why we why i love springs and why
you should also care about the sprints
and um again you know shameless uh
advertisement about my twitch channel
so i love teaching piper as well so
that's why i do this tutorials online
and i really like it so
and um yeah i would first start to talk
as
uh how i got started and uh i would like
to see if i can see the chat because i
would like to see if uh
if you know because like this zoom thing
is a little bit uh strange for me
and especially when i share my screen i
can't really see where everything's
are so yeah sorry about that so if
if there's any question in the chat
maybe uh the host you can uh
you can help me out by uh you know um
shouting the questions to me and i i
wanted to better highlight that for you
yeah great so yeah i will start uh i'll
start by uh
telling you a little bit more about how
i got started so
um i was i i started uh
yeah i started my um
okay it's just yeah okay yeah the
control is a little bit weird as well
with using zoom so
i i'm very good at using my uh twitch
thing but not very good assume sorry
about that
so i started my my journey of open
source contribution by um
joining the python sprints uh which now
i'm i'm one of the co-organizers
but at that time you know it was the
founder who organized it is
mark glacier i think maybe some of you
know him he's
also the maintainer of pandas and he's
also very
enthusiastic about contributing to open
source especially pandas of course
um at this time he he wasn't uh like
i think yeah when i met him he wasn't
the maintainers yet
and uh he was in the in the core team of
pandas and he
basically he was organizing all these
sprints and really like
helped promoting contribution to open
source i found it really cool
and at that time i was well i'm i'm
still based in london
and i was started in london and we we
just like re
meet regularly uh to contribute to uh
projects
so the first project that i contribute
to is um
i hope you recognize it but maybe it's
not that
that obvious this is stage 2 actually
it's uh some of you may heard about that
it's actually a a very
commonly used library so i still
remember the screen was uh in the
in the bloomberg office and it's a very
very nice office that
yeah thank you so much for you know
sponsoring us to have a sprint there
and that's how i started to send my
first pull request on github
i at that time i did have a github
account but i i never contributed any
open source project i was horrible at
git i
i didn't know you know i made a lot of
mistakes you know i
don't know how to i don't even know how
to run pi tests at the time
i was like um really you know really
zero i know nothing
but uh that's amazing about the sprint
is that you've got a lot of
experienced people there you've got um i
got like
you know the the maintainer of day 2
tears there
he was at that time he was working for
bloomberg but he wasn't based in london
he traveled there uh to
do to be like you know mentoring sprints
and he was super nice uh that that's
paul
um now he's also a core developer of c
python
and he's like really really a very good
uh
staff i would say and he's very patient
and
everybody in there is very patient as
well we also got like more
developers that is you know they're more
experienced with all this stuff that you
know um
on my git problem i was like hey help me
i got this like
emerge cornflakes what's going on i
screw up with kit
can you help me and um yeah and also
like
my pull request was like brutally
reviewed but it's it's
like it's not that you know brutally in
a way that you know it's not that
they're nasty it's just like
you know i have some white space at the
end or i have an empty
empty line that you know i have to
remove i was oh my god this is so
tedious but i learned a lot i learned a
lot
there and of course now i'm more
experienced i
i know how to make a full request i try
to teach people how to make a pull
request as well
i actually do have run like a couple of
workshops just for beginners
uh to how to contribute open source how
to make your first pull request on
github and all this stuff
um so so that's how i got started and of
course afterwards i go to a lot of
conference and
a lot of conference like this one i
would say that all the good conferences
had
half a sprint like uh that is at the end
so uh yeah
you know pi data uh you know this this
uh festival
um it also has the sprints on saturday
and um so i go to a lot of them i i
went to you know the one um you know
usually after the conference there's
also hacktoberfest that happen in
in october there's also events that
could
you know it's a place that people gather
to um
to work on open source projects and
usually uh
not all of them but usually there will
be mentors there that could uh that they
would be like maybe maintainer or maybe
more senior developers that they would
help you
answer your questions about that
particular project that we work on
so because um yeah sometimes you know
if you have it's the first time
contributing to a project that is quite
daunting
it's quite daunting that you don't know
what to do or like don't
don't know what to look at which
techniques to take which ticket is
maybe not for you to take because it's
too complicated
so um so having a mentor there is very
good i'll also explain why this is
good for the community as well in a you
know in late part of the talk
but uh but among all my experience i
wanted to mention one that is really
worth um
mentioning uh because it's also related
to minorities so
i believe it was uh euro python
uh in edinburgh so it was not
last year so it's the year before it's
2018. so it was in anniversary of studio
python
and i remember you know we have the two
spring day at the end
so before that there will be like a um
you know there'll be a bunch of talks
first of all like you know like no
any con you know most of the conference
i won't say any but like most of the
conference you have amazing talks
amazing speakers
but they also have a section that you
know would let uh
you know the the leader of the projects
that are going to join the sprints to
present their projects and i remember
that's this project i i
don't know whether you have heard about
it maybe some of you don't some of you
don't so
pipa or i i i say pipa
like i don't know whether that's the
correct pronunciation of it
so it's actually uh it's the
organization that maintain
pipe or project that maintained pi pi so
warehouse project is the project that
actually um
related to pipeline so what is pi pi pi
pi is where you
pip install your stuff so uh so all the
stuff that you pimp install the
libraries that you pick install actually
they stay in pi api so it's python uh
you know register
uh industry uh in industry like i forgot
the term
i'm bad with names so warehouse project
is is you know it's the project about
that
and um so so what happened is like
at that sprint that because well
all the developers you know present you
can imagine there'll be like mainly
guys who will be the co-maintainer of
the of the projects there's
even like uh you know c python uh
core developers there which like you
know a lot of people want to contribute
to c python because
you know um that's really cool you
contributed with the python itself and
uh
it's it's super cool so actually i can
now see the chat i
found found it and yeah hey hello
hello everybody sorry i was ignoring the
chat for a bit so uh
yeah so at that time like all the other
developers was
presenting the project but it stands out
to me that uh the
the leader of this project at that
sprint is
a lady and nico she's one of the
co-developers
of this warehouse project and i was like
okay i gotta join this project i think
part of it's because like it sounds like
a cool project you know it's like
it's contributing to the to the the
place this is the
webs you know web service like i don't
know how to say web
website that is um yes i think so i
think so i am back with name so uh
yes so thank you for taking up the full
name for me so a pipe is python
packaging authority yes that's correct
thank you
and um so yeah there was the lady who's
like presenting and part of it is
because like
i'm interested in this um project i
think it's super cool it's like
it's well see python is cool but like
this is kind of like the second cool
project
right so that i want to contribute to
and the other thing is like because
i really like her i really like because
i can relate to her that like i mean
like
you can think of like oh one day maybe i
want to become a
maintainer of a popular project as well
and you'll be like oh my god i really
want to
like get more chances to talk to her to
like maybe she can teach me a thing or
two
that's why i was like okay i'm joining
this project for sure i tried to talk to
her after
her presentation as well so i was like
great
and uh even though at the end i was like
i was not paying attention that for this
project actually you have to have
knowledge about how
where things work so basically i didn't
know i contributed nothing to the
project because i
i was not a web developer and like
uh like i said before i work for data
science you know i work in the data
science field so maybe like contributing
to pandas or numpy i kind of i have a
crew or two but
contributing the web related version is
kind of like contributing to jungle
like i have no idea how all this web
thing work
and it's not even using jungle you know
like the the pipey itself is using
um uh using pyramid so uh i was like i
have no idea what this pyramid and i
don't know how all these like web
framework works so like how how am i
gonna do so
but like you can see that it's kind of
one thing that affects my
my my my way how are looking at the
project
is like oh whether the maintainer like
who
is in the leadership team in the in in
the project so
hmm that rings a bell too so that's
actually related to what i'm going to
talk about later so
i'm sorry about like kind of i'm talking
a lot about like
my experience because this is actually
all related to what i'm trying to say
uh by the end of the day so for the next
slice
if i can go with the slice thank you
okay so um yeah why we need more
minority contributors and why
especially i would say that why we need
more minorities in the leadership
of the open source community so
to look at the uh to look at the the the
problem this way is that um because
uh i think i give a talk uh last year
that's about you know um you know the
diversity in the theater
so we have a play we have a play that
involve a lot of you know um
because like because you think uh the
diversity in the theater they have a
problem with
uh racial diversity so a lot of actors
or rose they are
you know they're caucasian white people
in more you know kind of rough term
then and then it's also you know people
usually the theater goal will be
caucasian they'll be like upper middle
class
you know people go and uh so this is
this is a problem and
nowadays you know like if you're a
theater lover like me that who also
happened to base in a big city like
london that got a lot of shows every day
uh not now but
you know before the pandemic that uh you
know now
things are changing because this try to
have place that try to target on
minorities you know ethical minorities
and having actors
from a more like uh ethnical like
diversity background to join
so it's the same it's the same for like
if you're one more minority contributors
you have to have uh or even like more
uh more people who is like different
from the
stereotype majority kind of stereotype
people who would be interested in open
source you have to have a leadership
that actually is different you know it's
not just
one demographic of people who who are
the leaders
in the open source community so
so diversity leadership actually uh is
well
it's actually a good thing so that's why
a lot of companies try to
achieve that even though how effective
they are achieving it i
i would have a doubt uh opinion on it
but
uh you know but at least there's this
study by
mckinsey uh this is from a source that's
in 2018 so it's
just a few years ago that a diversity
like a
diversity leadership team actually
performs better so the company like
if it's a company of course the one of
the benchmark one of the you know the
the reference the benchmark would be
like how how financially you perform
and actually it's like 21 more likely to
perform better if you have a diversity
leadership team
and also the benefits of having a
diversity leadership is that you would
bring in new ideas so people who is from
a cultural background like different
cultural background
they would have you know different way
of looking at things
and it's also create more debate so it's
like always doubles you know
you sometimes when you make the decision
if everybody just agree on it it may be
a bad decision just like
it's just happened that because you know
people don't have
a second look on the issues so that
decision could be made
like uh would end up be a bad decision
so
actually having a diversity in
leadership is good and
us we want to have more minority
contributors especially like
contributors who are you know
it's like a pyramid right if you have
more uh people come
in from a minority group as a
contributor then you know if they
encourage to keep contributing at the
end of the day they will become a
very you know major contributors and
they will become
the maintainer or the leadership team
right
so so yeah that's why we actually really
need to have
more um minority joining this workforce
to have a very healthy
open source community and but
while all of these are so ideal like we
all know that is good like i think i
hope you
at this point more or less agree with me
that we want diversity
um but yeah there are actually problems
there are actually problems right now
it's not as bad as if you compare maybe
20 years ago
it may not be as bad but we still have
the problem here
i try to find some statistics try to um
show you the problems
and but one that is just before i show
you the statistic i talk about my
observation as well
so in in the past you know if you go to
uh let's say
i don't want to name any like events but
there's you know if it's an open source
focus event that you will see that
most of the attendees will be you know
um
i hated to say it but that's true at
least in the
in the you know in in europe and in also
in north america would be
you know uh well also you know open
source developers would be
people picture okay a caucasian guy
that's like maybe
um you know they could be young but they
could do all the days
they would be you know oh you know um
caucasian guys okay
so um that's what people think right
but i would say that recently if you go
to an open source focused event
you can see like there's actually some
some sprinkles of different
uh different spectrum of people there
you can see women there you can see
people who
are not um you know caucasian have a
more diverse racial background
you know you can have actually uh people
who may be like
you they're they're good hate to judge
people but they look but some people
they obviously they
they're very proud to address like they
are from
let's say a minority com community like
lgbtq community
and um they they would you know you can
feel that the
diversity is happening there just by who
is attending those events so
actually it's like it's it's improving
but still we still have the problem
we're far from finish um so statistic
okay now like because we uh with we have
thai data we love statistics so i gotta
talk a little bit like
with the data to show you so this is the
day of the october so this is a
um a statistic that's done by github
so um i do believe this is the data for
uh you know for last year so you can see
the graph is like
you know stopped at 2019 since last
year's data
as of last year so you can see that
actually this is
um where the contributors are from so
this is a
picture that actually i grabbed from
there from actually the link is in the
inside so i can
maybe as i was as well show you so um so
yeah this is
the whole survey here so there's
actually a lot of different aspects in
there uh you can see
uh they do a very generous survey about
like maybe
which language is more popular and other
stuff but of course today we're going to
talk about minorities so i gotta
look at it at which region peop uh
contributors are from
so i'm quite happy that you know hong
kong is kind of like
growing very fast because i i'm actually
from hong kong if you uh
did a note so i should have told you and
this is one of the things that i was
quite proud of as well the more
more open source contributor from hong
kong uh even though i've
i've not been in touch with the tech
community there for
like ever i would say because i started
my tech career here in london but
anyway back to back to this graph so so
you can see that
asia is going very well you know it goes
from maybe like
five years ago that it was you know um
you know now it's like you know it's
kind of ahead of you know uh
europe and north america it grows very
very fast but
uh but you see that this is there's the
region that's still
uh behind you know north south america
you know we we
like the growth is not as good as we
hope even though we know that there are
actually more development in technology
for example in countries like brazil
and um bots you know the open source you
know
environment is not growing as fast of
course
africa as well um i know that uh because
i'm really
i really love the the pycon community in
africa and also i'm paying attention to
like other communities there
but still i i guess still that uh you
know the struggle i've been to in the
media
i know that you know they may not have
that good access
to the internet to to you know to have
these resources
for some some places but um so yeah
you can see that even in wikipedia that
uh there is actually a statement there
saying like
um black people and latinos so this is
not just
region wise this is kind of like racial
wise it's like they're considered to be
underrepresented
um so if yeah you can actually look at
the wikipedia this to see
uh the explanation of it but um
so there's also the it's not just gender
you know um
unbalanced it's also kind of racial and
regional and balanced there as well
um so that that's the problem that we
have at least
uh globally because that now or
everything go online so you would be
more aware of this
because before you may organize you know
conferences or organize events in your
own region so you have you only care
about your own region but now
like we look globally so there's
actually there are there
are regions that maybe it's not that
many active uh contributors there so
maybe
we should pay more attention to that uh
imbalance
and also again like this is the topic
that
has been just discussed many many times
so
it's not difficult to find articles that
talk about that you know women women in
open source
and this is actually a survey done by uh
this company
um top tacto and um
so they have this article talk about um
you know women opens also i
extract some of their their findings
there and
um so you see that you know uh
like just you know five percent of the
github user like
with 10 contributions and oh
okay i i'm kind of uh running half time
so i'll go faster don't worry i i would
be
going faster so yeah and you know we
you can look at the figures there's not
that many active uh you know women
contributors in open source
so so why is the case so actually i
won't read this
whole thing out so basically what i want
to say here is that
um because women don't feel safe in an
environment that they contribute online
because
well like even though i know the python
community is lovely but
generally like sometimes in open source
world when you
you know do some you know contribute
some code then people would be like you
know commenting on it
not with a very nice tone or like in a
very
judgmental way or even sometimes brutal
and sometimes you know
yeah it's like so women don't feel safe
online uh there's a lot of uh misogyny
there
uh i don't have time to explain that but
i think i've given talk before talking
about like uh
researching these misogynist online that
you know so women don't feel safe going
on the internet
so asking them to contribute only if you
online is quite difficult actually
so um what the community can do to
change that what the community could
actually change this environment and you
know encourage more minority
contribution
contributions so first of all to to
tackle that problem
we need to create a safe space for
everyone so a code of conduct even
though like
i know events usually have code of
conduct but even though if it's just
online project if you have a project
put up a code of conduct and ask
everybody to behave
you know to behave you know con you know
under the code of conduct
um even when they come in and anything
also we have to put an effort to
encourage diversity maybe we should
looking at those regions try to like
encourage you know maybe having more
sprints
in those regions so because springs like
you know if you
uh recall what i said at the beginning
of the talk my experience
i was brought in by friends so having a
mentored sprint having a mentor there to
help
actually really help so maybe try to
mentor some minority
you know people from minority groups to
to contribute
and also celebrate diversity publish
your figure if you're
like you know do some statistics look at
the data like looking at how things got
improved like the
like the one in in the octoverse you
know that graph that i showed you you
can see asia is growing very fast
so i hope the other regions could also
grow very fast as well like asia
so celebrate that win celebrate that
diversity
and so and the last thing that i want to
talk about that i
want to give you is that what you can do
so this is mainly applies to people who
identify themselves as minority whether
you're racial minority
gender minority whatever if you are not
if
you're like unfortunately i am the
majority people what should i do you can
be an ally you can encourage
anyone you know maybe your colleague
your friends or even your partner
that you know that is a minority person
to do
this thing so start contributing start
going to the sprint like when i started
i was zero i told you i did
i don't know how to use skit right so
everybody can just start
just start from whenever you wherever
you are right don't worry about that
try to go to the sprint get yourself a
mentor get involved
so uh you know contribute contribute and
contribute
um you know you can even like running
the screens you know organized streams
is also a contributing mentor people is
also contributing
getting involved sign up with psf and to
become a voting member is also getting
involved
because you would vote for who become
the leadership of the psf
leadership of python community right
also
become a role model so if there's a
point that you think that i can do that
i can organize this thing
i can be the leader i can be a
maintainer like i created the project
if you're a minority person be the role
model just like you know when i met
nicole it's like because
oh my god like you inspire people that
is similar to you
to start contributing as well so don't
worry celebrate your success
stand out there and to share your
experience with people so that's what i
would recommend you to do
so i hope i don't horribly overrun and
i'm afraid i don't have time for q a
but i'll be in the chat i will be
hanging on this course
so um talk to me there and i and
yeah that's it thank you for for for my
talk and this is the last slide that i
got to show you
join the sprint this saturday that's a
good start and
also there's other sprints that's going
to happen in other conferences as well
the dates are there
so pay attention to those um i know that
the euro python one is free to join the
sprint so you can just register
so um that's it i'll leave you with that
so um yeah thank you so much
thank you so much for talk um coming
from a
white dude in tech i'm very much looking
forward to seeing a more diverse crowd
at future events
um maybe there's like time for this one
single super
short question are you gonna join us for
the sprint on saturday
yay yeah there you go awesome